now all we've done from a previous
question right is we change the Familia
monthly okay now what that means is for
the numbers there's gonna be seven
significant differences it's a little
bit like we're gonna be integration
right and we give you something and we
say integrate and get a definite
integral from A to B of some function
right and then we say and use this
substitution right so we change it into
in terms of X's we change it to use you
seen that kind of question so what you
end up with is you're integrating a
function of U with respect to U right
now when you do that you can't just
leave these limits as they were but
you've got to change them to some other
limits in terms of U instead of X so
save do gr because I've changed
everything to monthly instead of viewing
all of the details I supplied the
question I've got over two shafts so
that there in terms of one times you
know okay so I'm looking at this row
here instead of five years I need to
think about this as 16 months right and
in the same way because the arm because
the interest is getting calculated more
frequently I shouldn't think about 15
percent per annum because it's monthly
I'm gonna have to divide that by 12
because that's how much interest I'll
get everyone right so 15 percent per
annum
I think it works out to one point two
five percent okay so these are gonna be
the bits and pieces that are going to go
into our new series okay so before we
actually work out how much is gonna save
we're gonna work out what the actual
repayment
that's that's why I've circle what every
scheme of me trying to work out here
right and this is sort of the blank so
how do you work out the repayment and
you gotta be careful it is attractive
for you zoom in much the same way as you
did the previous question except all the
numbers so we want a see the amount
owing on to 60
time periods in this case we wanted to
be equal to zero so what's the
expression for a 60 it's gonna be a
little different from one's a 60 should
be equal to than 50 grand that we start
off already
right and because it sits there for 60
time periods it's gonna get 60 watts an
interest applied to it right and that's
why the Forbes 500 tips so one this is
point zero one two five sorry that's
receiver ^ 60 so that represents what we
started with right and then you subtract
your repayments this is where the series
comes in
do you remember let's learn our
repayment BP cuz I don't know what it is
yet and that's going to become a problem
for us later on his receipt it's gonna
be P times now what what goes into the
series what's in the series I think for
memory up on the top here this is your
part of the N minus 1 right yeah the Sun
so this is now and now and it's still 60
right minus 1 and then on your
denominator sorry what's that doing
there under so many of you are minus 1
okay so 0.05 does that check out so far
okay give me some bullets yes okay and
we want that to be a [ __ ] road okay so
you've rearranged a little bit and we
want wimpy right so I'm guessing I'll
kick this 50,000 over the other side and
then this part is going to cross
multiply right so I'll have this 0.0125
on the top and I'll have the other pot
okay now what calculated others you get
for that
yeah one one eight nine okay let's let's
get to something something something in
this case right I think it's like six
five I think that's enough okay now this
is a really unusual example I didn't you
say this I'm glad I came around some of
you will get to this point and you say
well okay my question is about over the
life of the loan right so you could say
okay well a reasonable assumption is you
take that value and you multiply it by
how many times he repays it namely 60
times okay and then I'll tell you how
much she's paying over the life of the
loan okay but there's a problem with
this we're doing this because if I had
ended the question is said what's his
monthly repayment how much does he have
to pay every month what would you
conclude off this what value is you
actually pulled out you have to get
around don't you
you'd say lightly but the monthly your
pay would turn for nine and it had to go
up you have to go up to fifty cents
because I wrote it down to 49 cents even
if I was close to the point line says I
wouldn't actually finish the repayment
that little bit would catch me by
getting used to me I mean you know I
mean like seven cents by the end of the
word or something it goes like that okay
so therefore I have to say I took her up
this is how much yes to pay every month
because you know if you go to a bank and
say I'm gonna pay you forty nine point
six five cent they'll say get lost say
you know actual all sets here okay so
that's is actually payment now that I go
to the life of the loan this is what I
multiply by 16 not this cuz I can't
replace
because he's been bit Soviet
recollection Hey okay but this I can
paste it two times for Johnny anyway
okay no you might think doesn't make
that much of a difference well guess
what
that's six five makes twenty six
difference any sense that's it okay
couldn't convince us more so over the
life of the loan his total repayment is
a this.value time see some governments
70-something 7300 and and that's no
senses their zero sense right okay so
there is how much you will pay a laugh
at alone with monthly repayments if I
want to work out how much you pay if we
did this you multiply this by 5 right x
578 this must be so much for something
isn't it somewhere here five sub okay so
now we've actually gotten all of the
pieces together and actually I can work
out what the saving is right this is
about three grand
okay okay so that was a good example of
a question because there's also a little
booster form into and it's lots of
natural steps to go through before you
can actually answer the question at all
but you have a little bit it's just a
subtraction so okay know how to finish
that question come back to your table
right we've asked a lot of questions
here for Johnny and his time papers but
there's one glaring question that's
missing
because as you know
we've been sort of looking at different
quantities and trying to solve for
different quantities you know for
example here with interest rate I've
deliberately let that off okay because
it leads to a question which you can't
it's so in sum we walk without some we'd
methods you don't know yeah so what does
that leave it leaves that amount over on
the Left right suppose Johnny says look
okay um
three grand is actually not that much
for saving so this is my oh that's not
good of the I can't do it I've still
just got it
I've still just got five years and I can
make a repayment of ten grand
okay and he decides that the UM here in
my place not worth the effort so it just
goes with back to the annual plan it has
some cash for you know if he's on his
descendants after him so he doesn't want
to leave a debt behind so doesn't
actually want to repay it and he's still
stuck with this fifteen percent interest
rate okay so the London question is well
if that's how much you can repay this is
how much money has got left
well how much can he really borrow I
welcome out Kenny actually borrow and be
able to be paid in that's one so let
your pirate amount be B dollars and give
go is our last question of Johnny at
home we'll let it rest in peace I'm see
if you can work out how much you can
actually yeah